il était juste un autre gi à l'armée
pendant 17 mois en allemagne mais maintenant il est à nouveau
le populaire elvis un
favori accrocheur alors qu'il se prépare à mettre fin à sa
carrière militaire
à fort dix new jersey la presse est
en force pour le sergent elvis presley
nancy sinatra  nancy jr elle s'appelle est
parmi des amis présents
elvis va avoir un véritable accueil à la
maison sur les chapiteaux de cinéma de la nation
où ils joueront son hit de tous les temps
mgm jailhouse rock dans lequel il chante
sept chansons
et maintenant
l'idole du rock and roll  fait face calmement aux
microphones
il a la question évidente qui lui est
posée deux ans de vie dans l'armée qui donne à réfléchir a
changé d'avis sur le rock and roll la
vie dans l'armée qui donne à réfléchir
chars pendant longtemps vous voyez
et
ils rock and roll un peu